rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message learn how to think critically
over to you Jordan Peterson the best
thing you can do is teach people to
write because there's no difference
between that and thinking and one of the
things that just blows me away about
universities is that no one ever tells
students why they should write something
it's like well you have to do this
assignment well why are you writing well
you need the grade it's like no you need
to learn to think because thinking makes
you act effectively in the world
thinking makes you win the battles you
undertake and those could be battles for
good things if you can think and speak
and write you are absolutely deadly
nothing can get in your way so that's
why you learn to write it's like when I
can't believe that people aren't just
told that it's it's it's like it's the
most powerful weapon you can possibly
provide someone with and I mean I know
lots of people who have been
staggeringly successful and watched them
throughout my life I mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and then not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're gonna make your point and
they're gonna make their point you
better have your points organized
because otherwise you are gonna look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not gonna get anywhere and if you can
formulate your arguments coherently and
make a presentation if you can speak to
people if you can lay out a proposal god
people give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence being
able to communicate as one of the most
important skills that you could have as
an entrepreneur and that could be
through writing it could be through
public speaking it could be through
one-on-one conversations it could be by
making videos or being a great
interviewer being able to communicate
your thoughts is important because you
can't do this alone
you need to have other people join your
mission and the more of those skills you
can develop writing speaking video all
of those things and more the skills that
you can develop the more powerful you're
gonna be but you also have to have a
message to share right you could be a
great public
speaker great on video or a great writer
but if you don't have powerful opinions
in the powerful mission you haven't
thought through what you're saying then
you're not gonna bring people on board
and so that's where I find real value in
a channel like this selfishly for myself
and hopefully you guys get value too
when I see Elon Musk sharing his vision
for Mars when I see Jordan Peterson
sharing some of his thoughts when I see
Oprah Winfrey and Priyanka Chopra and
all the people that we profile I'm a
daily basis every time I hang around
somebody who's had massive success a
little bit of that magic dust a little
piece of them falls into me to help me
think bigger think more strategically
think more critically get new ideas and
so I think it's that combination I think
in terms of the ability to communicate
comes with practice right if you want to
write you don't just wake up when you're
a great writer you meet the practice you
want to be good on video you want to be
a youtuber you have to practice right
I've done 5,000 almost 6,000 videos now
on my channel some of them are not
listed and I've had people on who are
the most energetic outgoing fun-loving
bubbly people but then you put them in
front of a camera and they freeze up and
they're nervous and they're scared
because they haven't done it before and
so you need to practice to get that
skill down so that you can be really
good at it for me it's probably taking
me a lot longer than how quickly other
people could go it doesn't necessarily
take you six thousand videos to get to
be where are my level is at and I still
have further to go to to catch up to
others I'm not done on my growth the
other side though about learning to
think strategically so that then you can
communicate these great ideas I think
really comes down to how much more you
put it into your brain look it's the the
input in leads to good input out the
more great knowledge you're feeding
yourself with the more you'll think and
digest it and then be able to form your
opinions and communicate it out in a
powerful way if you're constantly
surrounded by negativity small thinking
routine and boredom and you're not
growing then don't expect to have this
powerful message it's gonna be able to
influence a lot of people and so
whatever that thing is for you has to be
built in at least in my opinion into
part of your daily
team if it's reading books if it's
listening to podcast who's watching
videos if it's having conversations
whatever your method of learning is you
need to be constantly growing and having
that as part of your daily routine and
then practicing the skill of
communicating your mission in your
message that you can bring people on
board and go off and change the world
you need both so the question today
today is I'm curious what is the thing
that you do on a daily basis to feed
your brain fill it with knowledge and
help kind of bring up your mind set to
thinking a bigger game what is that
habit leaving the comments below
I'm really curious to find out I also
want to give a quick charter to Greg
Orlando Greg thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book the top ten
rows to success and taking that picture
and sharing it with me I really
appreciate it man and I hope you enjoyed
the read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spresso
[Music]
truth is a pathless land you know we've
all got our own personal truths there
are certain principles they'll help
align us all just be true to your
essential self thank our people over and
they're part of that yeah it's a bit
annoying Tesco I think's really
important it's like you don't like say
when I was a kid it was all-out
apartheid and all that sort of stuff and
also woodruf tend to be sort of angry
about it and obviously I agree with
complete racial integration and racial
equality but actually when I was at home
at night I won't actually I think
roofing who upload your particle sleep
you know didn't bother me really like
but I say when I got ripped off like a
bus driver and give me my fare back or
when there's an ATM charge of 350 I'm
prepared and kill Oh an apple change
their charger changing charges for you
know that stuff really affects me and
impacts me you know so what I think we
have to do is recognize where in our own
lives we've been ripped off with a
ripping us off left them right you know
like we've recognized where those things
are recognize that those things are not
necessary and when people tell you
they're there is no alternative look at
the people who are telling you that
there's no alternative to this system
that happens to benefit me oh that's
convenient we've looked at all the
alternatives and the best one is me in a
big council thanks well they'll stop
thinking debate over think things out
for yourself come to your own judgments
don't simply conform to conventional
ways of thinking conventional ways of
dressing conventional ways of acting
that a lot of this a lot of things are
based on fashion even morality at times
is based on fashion it was once fact you
know slavery was once not because
they're not to be immoral you know
people are you know people are shocked
that the ancient Greeks had slaves that
it that we had slavery in this country
as recently isn't you know 130 hundred
forty years ago so there are moral value
you have to really go back to first
principles don't think things out for
yourself whether they're scientific
principles or moral principles or
business ideas or product ideas you have
to think things out yourself and I was
just so excited to tell my friends I was
like man they're gonna be just like so
fired up for me I figured it out I'm not
going to be stressed anymore and I'm
guys I'm gonna major in computer science
and one of my friends said wow that's
the stupidest thing I've ever heard
and I'm like why he said like you're at
Columbia University that's like a trade
you can learn that at DeVry they'll
teach you how to build computers fix
them program them like you should major
in something real and I was just
thinking to myself I was like I'm
talking about a limitless machine you're
like talking about a washing machine but
I was so frustrated I couldn't even
really explain to him why but it was at
that point that my like height of
frustration that I learned the most
valuable lesson that I learned at
Columbia which is don't listen to your
friends
[Applause]
and the more the more generalized the
more generalized case of don't listen to
your friends is think for yourself and
thinking for yourself sounds simple and
trivial but in reality it's extremely
difficult and it's profound and here's
why as human beings we want to be liked
it's anthropological if people didn't
like you in caveman days they would just
eat you so you really have a natural
built-in instinct to want to be liked
and the easiest way to be liked is to
tell people what they want to hear and
you know what everybody wants to hear
what they already believe to be true and
so the last thing they want to hear is
an original idea that contradicts their
belief system so it's very hard to even
bring that kind of stuff up but those
are the things those are the only things
things that you believe that everybody
around you doesn't believe when you're
right that create real value in the
world everything else people already
know there's no value created it's just
business as usual so it's so important
to think for yourself if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details